yo what's up gq it's marshmallow i'm
here to talk about some essential items
that i need every day in my life i'm
gonna share them with you
so we're going to start with my first
essential
which is the usb it might not seem like
much but this is what all of the audio
and basically the whole show when i play
a show runs off of i don't have it or i
don't have my backups there's nothing we
can have all the lights and stuff but
there'll be no audio super super super
essential
[Music]
alienware gaming laptop i love playing
video games as much as i can
specifically on tour this is the easiest
way to travel and play you don't have to
carry a huge console around so i'll
bring like a keyboard and a mouse and
play on this i can just have pretty much
any game
on here other people in my crew on the
road will bring laptops as well and
we'll all just be in my hotel room and
play video games all the time so a lot
of call of duty on a fortnight
like a marshmallow running around
in fortnight yeah there already is
yeah yeah we dropped it like three years
ago it's actually like a super sought
after skin when it drops it's like i
always see it on twitter it's like
trending i'm like what like what's going
on why am i trending and it's always
talking about my skin and fortnite
[Music]
jordan ones
um these are the trophy room jordan ones
collab they're sweet they're a little
dirty i wore these shoes at lollapalooza
they got a signature right here a little
sparkly i don't know if you can see that
on camera when you look at them straight
they're like colored but if you move
they sparkle every show for the most
part i'm gonna be wearing jordan once
they're just super comfy and durable i
can move around when i lace them up like
tight you can move around feels good and
this is definitely essential to a show i
like like simple like nothing crazy
colors and stuff like that so anything
with the
white as the main and then the colors i
i really like how many jordan ones i own
i own probably about around 50 pairs
easily
for my next essential we got the
backbone iphone gaming controller this
is insanely awesome you could play all
your games and stuff with this thing
it's basically like playing like uh on
an xbox or whatever but you can be
sitting in the van on the way the
airport or on the plane you actually
also have like a huge advantage using
this too playing online phone games
because most people are on their phones
clicking but you have all these i just
love it so much
this is a
super super super fire have you ever
like thrown that out of anger
cause then i'd be throwing my phone now
controllers on the other hand i've
thrown controllers for sure but that's
just because i want to win man and then
it doesn't happen you know you just get
get a little upset
and now
my legs essential stuff puffs these are
the big bites they already have the
chocolate inside of them for example
this is s'mores this is rolled in like
graham cracker with the chocolate inside
so it's like the samoan bite
this is the uh the birthday cake so the
inside isn't chocolate it has like that
funfetti type stuff and then there's the
cookies and cream everybody loves these
i eat a little bit too much of them you
can melt them down and make rice
krispies treats with them i've done that
personally anything you want you make
cookies with them
rice krispies anything there's so far
love them
[Music]
rx nut butter it's a pretty wild name
but it tastes super super super good i
put this on everything i can either with
fruit uh it's a great snack and it'll
like fill you up too so when you need to
eat quick it's good with calories and
stuff like that so i'll just eat it
straight as well this is like an
everyday thing legit they have some
other
flavors but this is my main
definitely my main one right here i have
like a
stockpile at my house
[Music]
hot sauce in general but this specific
hot sauce torch bearer it's super super
super spicy but i love it i actually put
it on pretty much everything that
requires hot sauce you know it obviously
hurts with spicy stuff but
i like i i don't really like the feeling
but it's like super intense so that's
it's fun i was in north carolina on tour
when i first started touring
went to this place called buffalo
brothers they had this wing chart right
so at the top it was ludacris
and we were with the whole tour all
sitting around a table
and i was like and a lot of us on the
tour team we all are like down with hot
sauces we send each other like hot
sauces hot sauce pictures make our own
stuff like that and we're like oh yeah
we're gonna take a little chris they're
like are you sure we're like yeah
they're like okay we're gonna go get the
waivers that you have to sign
and we're like what we designed this
like release form
that we could eat these wings because
they were so spicy and i'm thinking oh
whatever they're just doing that because
it's like a huge thing but no as soon as
they put down the wings and it was like
i i didn't even touch him it was like
everybody's getting mace like you
couldn't like open your eyes
you couldn't like breathe it was crazy
and uh
we all did it and that was easily the
spiciest thing i've ever had
[Music]
all right so for my next essential would
be amiri pants i could have brought any
amiri pants but i decided to bring the
coolest ones i own right here
i'm also wearing them right now
they're super durable and fit great and
i have these in mirrory pants and
actually this whole outfit right here
this is actually a one of one that mike
made for me for
my performance at the uefa championships
for soccer he made this custom white and
gray
outfit for me and i'm super thankful for
that and super grateful so shout out
mike
pretty sweet
gucci guilty i've uh always worn this
and you know it makes you smell good and
makes you feel good you know
[Music]
yeah no i don't make sense i i actually
watched uzi's essential and he was like
he wears
one and then two and then four and i'm
like i didn't even know you're supposed
to mix like i just
i just have the one and call it a day
nothing too complicated
last but not least my most let's say
most essential
in my everyday life
my touring life
everything in between
is
the marshmallow helmet
i obviously need this everywhere i go
every show i play every interview i do
i've been through a lot of
versions i'm obviously wearing the most
recent version and this is the the
version right before this one but
they're still essentially the same just
some different materials here and there
but this is probably my
ninth kind of
generation of the marshall helmet as we
kept going they kept getting lighter and
lighter so they're easier and they
aren't as harsh on my back and my neck
and stuff actually the first show i had
was skrillex and dj slink in new york
for halloween
2015. we bring the helmet and we don't
know anything i'm with i think just my
manager mo and we get onto the plane
and
i put the i put the helmet i carry it on
we get it through tsa
they like scan it they're like what the
hell is this
i get it and put it in the overhead and
it fits in
fine going in
and we just got it it's brand new never
been worn meanwhile this this helmet was
i think the helmet back then was about
13 pounds
so there was like kevlar in it and like
this this part was like perforated steel
super heavy i put it into the overhead
cool we get out
i'm pulling it out and it won't get out
but we really have to go i'm in a hurry
so i rip it out i hear cracking all this
stuff i'm like
[ __ ] so
we get out of the
plane and
the
mouth is all the jaws all cracked all
this stuff and we're freaking out we
don't
we don't have the money and we don't
have the
manpower we we can't get a helmet
overnight we're like what do we do what
do we do what do we do so we go to like
spirit of halloween or something and we
like put bandages on all the cracks and
put blood all over it so it's like for
halloween right and then before we could
get a fix when it was november for
thanksgiving we put like
feathers so it's like for turkey and
then for christmas we did like a candy
cane with red tape and taped over we ran
we really ran with that before we could
get a new helmet because we didn't have
money to buy another one and it was just
too much right it was just too little
time because i was playing so many shows
you know
so
yeah and then uh that's a story
all right that is the end of my
essentials list thank you gq for having
me you guys heard me talk about
my wardrobe stuff the food that i eat
the way that i play video games on the
road the way i do my shows and yeah see
you guys next time